[Musique]
moi
je
[Musique]
je joue pas un morceau l'âge improvise
j'essaye des notes c'est pas parfait
peu importe je cherche j'essaye j'essaye
[Applaudissements]
peu importe que ce soit parfait
là je travaille je m'amuse un peu je
joue je cherche
parce que je suis un chercheur mon
métier mon domaine de recherche
c'est la chirurgie assistée par
ordinateur je travaille avec des
chirurgiens
je ne suis pas un chirurgien moi même là
c'est moi avec un bonnet bleu vous avez
j'aime bien les bonnets bref ma porte je
travaille avec des chirurgiens mais je
ne suis pas un chirurgien mon domaine
c'est mes compétences que j'ai appris à
l'école sont les mathématiques la
physique et l'informatique
alors je suis pas un crack dans ces
domaines non plus mais j'arrive à
m'exprimer avec alors vous allez me
demander comment je peux être directeur
de recherche à l'institut national pour
la santé et la recherche médicale et
président de la société scientifique
internationale de chirurgie assistée par
ordinateur moi je vais vous l'expliquer
c'est simple c'est simple j'ai une
méthode la mienne c'est juste la mienne
d'abord j'aime j'aime découvrir
j'avais essayé j'aime apprendre
comprendre je suis patient j'essaye
j'essaye encore et encore je travaille
pas tout seul
je travaille avec des gens avec beaucoup
de gens en réseau je vais chercher les
compétences un peu partout j'essaye dans
tous les domaines vous allez voir
j'essaye partout mais partout vous allez
voir et je donne je donne beaucoup
donnent beaucoup je donne des idées
j'admets idée je donne des émotions et
puis j'ai pas peur pas peur même pas
peur même pas mal et même si j'ai peur
je fais quand même parce que parfois
j'ai peur j'ai peur de rater
j'ai peur des idées j'ai peur de mal
jouer mais je fais quand même
alors je vais vous présenter un petit
peu tout ça dans les minutes qui vont
suivre avec quelques exemples suivez moi
je suis dans mon métier de chercheur
confrontés à des problèmes comme celui
là je vous présente eric eric c'est un
patient qui a une dystonie la dystonie
c'est une maladie neurologique à
troubles moteurs
c'est un peu comme la maladie de
parkinson sauf que la dystonie ce sont
des contractions musculaires
involontaires
il ya une trentaine d'années environ
un neurochirurgien français a inventé
une technique qui s'appelle la
stimulation cérébrale profonde et qui
consiste à insérer dans le cerveau du
patient de toutes petites électrodes à
l'intérieur du cerveau et qui vont aller
stimuler électriquement de petites
structures et en les stimulant en
continu électriquement tout le temps ça
marche on voit eric trois ans après il a
grandi il a changé et ces troubles
moteurs ont disparu alors éric n'est pas
guéri mais ces troubles moteurs ont
disparu par la stimulation comme le
cerveau est un peu complexe
quand on stimule à un endroit on stimule
un petit peu partout autour comme les
neurochirurgiens et les neurologues
ne sont pas complètement d'accord sur
l'endroit n'y a pas un consensus exactes
sur l'endroit où il faut stimuler et que
probablement il faut stimuler des zones
différentes pour chaque patient il ya
chez certains patients des effets
secondaires négatifs des troupes de
l'émotion de l'apathie et parfois même
l'apparition d' addiction comme
l'addiction au jeu personnes avaient pas
d'addiction avant et puis avec la
stimulation acquérir acquiert une une
addiction
c'est là que moi j'interviens c'est là
qu'en tant que chercheur commence mon
travail
alors comment je fais je vais d'abord
aller chercher mes compétences de base
en mathématiques physique informatique
et puis les compétences de mes collègues
et des supers chercheuse super
chercheurs super étudiante et super
étudiants qui travaillent avec moi et
qui ont entre parenthèses très souvent
des compétences qui sont supérieures aux
miennes peu importe je vais chercher
leurs compétences on travaille ensemble
et puis on essaye par exemple on
développe des méthodes qui à partir des
images médicales du patient permettent
de construire un cerveau virtuel 3d de
chaque patient sur lequel la
neurochirurgienne à rennes qui fête ses
opérations peut préparer son insertion
d'électrodes pourrait essayer d'être la
plus sûre possible en plus pour essayer
de prédire c'est effets secondaires
négatifs qui peuvent arriver chez
certains patients eh bien on va aller
collecter toutes les données des
patients avant la stimulation après la
stimulation et on va les étudier ces
données pour essayer de voir les cas qui
marchait et les cas qui ne marche pas
alors on utilise des méthodes comme
l'intelligence artificielle par exemple
qui nous permet de prédire cette pour
certains patients le fait que la
procédure va pas très bien marché ou
plus faut faire attention parce que là
il ya un effet secondaire qui risquent
d'apparaître et la neurochirurgienne
nous dit
ça marche ça marche les durées de
l'intervention sont plus courtes
les effets secondaires sont sur les
patients sont réduits et il ya quasiment
plus d'infections
alors là moi je suis content je sais pas
toujours comme ça mais là je suis
vraiment content c'est une recherche qui
aboutit alors on va un petit peu plus
loin cette neurochirurgienne on aimerait
savoir comment elle opère exactement
comment elle fait comment elle quel
instrument chirurgical elle utilise
combien de temps avec quelle séquence
alors on cherche des méthodes qui par
observation on va les observer en salle
d'op on va regarder ce qu'elle fait et
puis par observation
on va analyser sa pratique et on va en
extraire des graphes des modèles qui
exprime son métier
ces modèles peuvent nous servir par
exemple si on les applique sur les
infirmières de bloc opératoire on va
elle aussi observé ces modèles peuvent
nous servir pour construire des
environnements de réalités virtuelles
qui permettent à ses infirmières de bloc
opératoire de s'entraîner continue la
progression continue des projets de
recherche
aujourd'hui on commence jeudi le
laboratoire commence avec moi un projet
de recherche
alors vous en parlez pas trop parce que
j'ai pas publier encore là dessus et
donc ça reste entre nous c'est un projet
de recherche où on va on va finalement
étudié l'activité cérébrale du
chirurgien pendant qu'il opère alors pas
pendant qu'il opère parce que bon ça va
un peu dérangée on va commencer pendant
qu'il s'entraîne et on va mesurer
l'activité électrique de son cerveau
pendant que tu travailles avec comme
objectif derrière d'essayer d'identifier
la courbe de progression des chirurgiens
comment il réagit au stress comment il
réagit à un événement inattendu et on
pense que ont peu impacté comme ça la
progression et l'apprentissage du
chirurgien et après vous allez me dire
après pierre tu vas faire quoi après là
dans cinq ans dans dix ans
ou tu vas te retrouver qu'est ce qu'on
va être les idées donc comment élargir
ce champ de créativité
comment trouver comment ouvrir des
portes là aussi j'ai ma méthode très
simple je cherche partout alors partout
je cherche partout j'essaye partout
partout ça veut dire d'abord à
l'étranger je voyage je voyage beaucoup
je vais aux etats-unis au canada en
norvège en allemagne ou au japon
je travaille avec makoto qui est un
chirurgien japonais et on étudie
ensemble les différences de pratiques
entre les infirmières de bloc opératoire
française et des infirmières de bloc
opératoire japonaise et je regarde si
les méthodes que je développe à rennes
peuvent être utilisés au japon aux
états-unis au canada
j'essaye partout alors quand je vous dis
par tous et partout
c'est aussi dans tous les domaines je
travaille avec des vous avez vu
mathématicien et informaticien physicien
chirurgien urologue mais aussi avec un
professeur de management en entreprise
avec un professeur en design l'école des
beaux-arts de strasbourg
et puis j'ai essayé avec des acteurs
avec un guitariste de rock avec des
plasticiens avec un exemple les
plasticiens il ya trois quatre ans j'ai
rencontré fred et flavien qui sont deux
plasticiens qui font des installations
au numérique
moi j'avais envie de comprendre comment
le font pour travailler quelle est leur
démarche créative et je voulais
l'utiliser cette démarche créative pour
améliorer vous avez vu cette
représentation 3d du cerveau là et cette
représentation est un peu complexe et je
voulais faire en sorte que leur méthode
permet de la simplifier et permettent de
transmettre plus d'informations au
chirurgien
alors on s'est vu une fois deux fois
trois fois quatre fois on a fait plein
de réunions
j'ai présenté ce que je fais ils m'ont
présenté ce qu'il faisait
on
discute énormément énormément on
n'arrivait à rien ça peut marcher alors
pas du tout pas du tout bon ça arrive
c'est la recherche
on essaye des fois ça marche pas il ya
d'autres exemples
il ya un mois environ un mois et demi la
neurochirurgienne avec qui je travaille
qui s'occupe aussi de la chirurgie de
l'épilepsie donc la chirurgie
d'épilepsie c'est un peu particulier
c'est dans le cadre de patients
épileptiques sévère pour beaucoup de
crises d'épilepsie par jour est la seule
solution quand les médicaments ne marche
plus c'est d'aller enlever par chirurgie
la petite zone cérébrale qui a au départ
des crises d'épilepsie la
neurochirurgienne à jour arrive dans mon
bureau
bonjour pierre j'avais une idée
j'aimerais bien entendre la crise
d'épilepsie j'aimerais bien entendre
pour voir où et démarre à moi vous me
parlez de entendre en tant que je pense
musique deux trois joueurs avant j'avais
rencontré jesse récit c'est un musicien
qui fait de la musique électronique et
j'ai dit jessie te donne les signaux
enregistrés sur des patients
épileptiques et transforme de l'émoi en
musique
hélas ce que vous entendez ces les
premiers résultats que m'envoyaient
jesse juste mardi
j'essaye j'essaie je cherche je me
trompe je réussis c'est la recherche ici
même là avec vous en ce moment là sur la
scène
je cherche aussi je suis aussi dans mon
approche de chercheurs je donne je
communique
je donne les rares fois où il m'est
arrivé d'être sur une scène comme lala
en concert j'ai senti que il faut donner
il faut tout donner on reçoit qu'on
reçoit pas peu importe qu'il faut donner
c'est la base c'est la condition
nécessaire donc ici aussi je vous donne
je m'amuse aussi vous avez vu et je
travaille et puis je vais apprendre je
vais découvrir comme vous je rencontre
vous aussi aujourd'hui vous apprenez
découvrez rencontrer vous êtes aussi
dans une démarche de chercheurs
aujourd'hui la comme moi vous êtes des
chercheurs pour une vie meilleure
la nôtre et puis celle des autres ma
question c est vous c'est quoi votre
méthode
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
elodie we lost toujours oui et les gens
crient les gens crient aujourd'hui
les gens crient pour
aujourd'hui
latham turpin
[Musique]
qu'apporte cette séquence
o o
commun et l'absence pan lourd
mais pour moi la démence ou shu
[Musique]
et matin certains
c'est pas facile et riche mobile
je
c'est par 6 1 6 2
/
qu'importe c'est vague
de données
vomir à la porte de des crises
synagogue apporte un sens à la glisse
ouais m'ouvre emma l'habitude
enfin
et
c'est pas facile
b
c'est
[Musique]
/
ouvrez ouvrez à l'ours
je
et le mouv et vous mes frères du sang
[Musique]
artère ramener et le sens
e
tension à l'actuel baa
c'est pas facile
op
c'est ainsi la cible
/
c'est pas facile d'être
op
c'est
à 6 de lost est sûre
le
c'est pas facile d'être
c'est pas si facile de rester sur un fil
de tout
[Musique]